para marcar sitios para algún tipo de terapia,
como la acupuntura.
Claramente, si la piel más antigua que se ha visto
está toda tatuada,
significa que el tatuaje es una práctica muy antigua.
Pero avancemos a hoy y los tatuajes están en todas partes.
Casi 1 de 4 estadounidenses tiene un tatuaje,
Es una industria multimillonaria.
y si les encantan los tatuajes o los odian,
esta charla cambiará su forma de pensar sobre ellos.
¿Por qué los tatuajes son tan populares?
A diferencia de Ötzi, la mayoría usamos tatuajes para algún tipo de autoexpresión.
Personalmente, me encantan los tatuajes porque amo el arte.
y hay algo tan maravilloso para mí,
casi romántico, sobre cómo un tatuaje es una forma de arte
que no puede ser mercantilizado.
¿Correcto? Tu tatuaje vive y muere contigo.
No se puede comprar, vender o intercambiar,
así que su único valor es realmente personal para ti,
y eso me encanta.
Tiendo a gravitar hacia tatuajes muy coloridos.
porque estoy obsesionado con el color.
Imparto un curso en mi universidad.
Pero mi primer tatuaje fue un tatuaje negro,
como el de Ötzi.
Sí, hice ese cliché que hacen los jóvenes a veces.
y me hice un tatuaje en un idioma que ni siquiera puedo leer.
(Risas)
Vale, pero tenía 19 años,
Acababa de regresar de mi primer viaje al extranjero,
estuve en Japón en las montañas
meditando en los monasterios budistas,
y fue una experiencia muy significativa para mí,
Así que quería conmemorarlo con este caracter japonés y chino.
para "montaña"
Ahora, esto es lo que me sorprende.
Mi tatuaje de 14 años de antigüedad
y los tatuajes de 5 300 años de Ötzi
están hechos de la misma materia exacta:
hollín,
ese polvo negro de carbón
que se queda en la chimenea cuando se queman cosas.
Y si haces zoom, ya sea en mi tatuaje o en los tatuajes de Ötzi,
encontrarán que todos se ve algo así.
Un tatuaje no es más que un montón de diminutas partículas de pigmento,
hollín en este caso,
que queda atrapado en la dermis,
que es la capa de tejido justo debajo de la superficie de la piel.
Así que en más de 5 000 años,
hemos hecho muy poco para actualizar la tecnología del tatuaje,
aparte de tener acceso a más colores
y métodos de instalación ligeramente más eficientes.
Además de ser artista, también soy científico,
y dirijo un laboratorio que investiga la nanotecnología,
que es la ciencia de construir cosas con bloques de construcción ultrafinos,
miles de veces más pequeño incluso que el ancho de un cabello humano.
Y comencé a preguntarme,
¿cómo podría servir la nanotecnología al tatuaje?
Si los tatuajes son solo un montón de partículas en la piel,
¿podríamos intercambiar esas partículas por otras que hagan algo más interesante?
Aquí está mi gran idea:
Creo que los tatuajes pueden darte superpoderes.
(Risas)
No quiero decir que nos van a hacer volar,
pero sí creo que podemos tener superpoderes
en el sentido de que los tatuajes nos pueden dar nuevas habilidades
que actualmente no poseemos.
Al actualizar las partículas, podemos diseñar el tatuaje.
para que no solo cambie la apariencia de nuestra piel,
sino también la función de nuestra piel.
Déjenme enseñarles.
Este es un diagrama de una microcápsula.
Es una pequeña partícula hueca con una cubierta exterior protectora,
del tamaño de un pigmento de tatuaje,
y se puede llenar el interior con prácticamente lo que quieras.
¿Qué tal si ponemos materiales interesantes en estas microcápsulas
y tintas de tatuaje hechas con ellas?
¿Qué cosas podríamos hacer que hiciera un tatuaje?
¿Qué problemas podríamos resolver?
¿Qué limitaciones humanas podríamos superar?
Bueno, aquí una idea:
una de nuestras debilidades como humanos.
es que no podemos ver la luz ultravioleta o UV.
Es la parte de alta energía de la luz solar
que causa quemaduras solares y aumenta el riesgo de cáncer de piel.
Muchos animales e insectos pueden verla, pero nosotros no podemos.
Si pudiéramos, veríamos el protector solar cuando se aplica en nuestra piel.
Desafortunadamente, la mayoría no usamos protector solar,
y quienes lo hacemos
realmente no podemos decir cuándo desaparece, porque es invisible.
Es la razón principal por la que tratamos más de 5 millones de casos.
del cáncer de piel prevenible cada año solo en EE. UU.
lo que le cuesta a nuestra economía más de USD 5 mil millones anuales.
¿Cómo podríamos superar esta debilidad humana con un tatuaje?
Bueno, si el problema es que no podemos ver los rayos UV,
tal vez podamos hacer que un tatuaje los detecte por nosotros.
Así que pensé, ¿por qué no tomamos algunas microcápsulas,
cárguemosla con un tinte sensible a los rayos UV que cambie de color,
y hacer un tatuaje de tinta de eso?
Uno de los problemas de ser un tecnólogo del tatuaje
es encontrar sujetos de prueba dispuestos.
(Risas)
Y cuando llegó el momento de probar esta tinta de tatuaje,
pensé que era mejor no torturar a mis pobres estudiantes de grado.
así que decidí tatuar un par de puntos en mi propio brazo.
Y realmente funcionó. ¡Échenle un vistazo!
A estos tatuajes les llamo pecas solares
porque son alimentados por el sol.
En este momento, son invisibles,
pero tan pronto como los expongo a una luz UV, que actúa como el Sol...
ahí están, manchas azules.
No estoy usando protector solar en este video,
pero si lo hiciera, esas manchas azules no aparecerían,
y luego cuando el protector solar desapareciera de mi piel más tarde,
las pecas solares reaparecerían en luz UV.
Y yo sabría que era hora de volver a aplicar protector solar.
Así que estos tatuajes actúan como un indicador de ojo desnudo en tiempo real.
de la exposición a los rayos UV de tu piel.
Y por supuesto,
creo que hay muchas cosas artísticas que puedes hacer.
con un tatuaje que cambia de color como este,
Pero espero que también nos ayude a resolver un gran problema
de protección dérmica.
(Aplausos)
Déjenme darles otro ejemplo.
La temperatura normal del cuerpo humano es de entre 36 y 37 ° C,
y si caes fuera de ese rango,
se necesita atención médica de inmediato.
El problema es que los humanos no pueden detectar su propia temperatura corporal.
sin termómetro.
Pueden probar el viejo truco de la mano en la frente,
pero no hay evidencia científica que respalde eso.
(Risas)
¿Y si pudiéramos crear un termómetro tatuable
al que se puede acceder en cualquier momento?
¿Recuerdan que las pecas solares utilizan un tinte sensible a los rayos UV
dentro de las microcápsulas de la tinta del tatuaje?
Bueno, también se podría poner tintes sensibles al calor
dentro de microcápsulas
y hacer diferentes tintas de tatuaje
que cambien de color a diferentes temperaturas.
Supongamos que a 35,5, 36,5 y 37,5 °C.
Si pones las tintas una al lado de la otra,
ahora tienes una escala de temperatura
sintonizada con el cuerpo humano.
En este video, pueden ver los diferentes parches de tatuajes.
desapareciendo secuencialmente
como en la piel de cerdo en la que los probamos
al calentarla.
Si tuvieran que poner un tatuaje como este
en un lugar que estable a los cambios externos de la temperatura,
--¿tal vez dentro de la boca, tal vez en la parte posterior del labio?--
podrían leer la temperatura de su cuerpo en cualquier momento
solo mirando a su tatuaje en el espejo.
Increíble, ¿verdad?
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Otra limitación que tenemos como humanos
es que nuestra piel no conduce electricidad,
y eso puede ser algo bueno, pero no necesariamente...
(Risas)
si tienes un implante biomédico electrónico,
como un marcapasos por ejemplo.
Actualmente si se tiene un marcapasos,
se precisa cirugía cada 5 o 10 años para reemplazar la batería cuando se agota.
¿Y no sería bueno si, en cambio,
se pudiera simplemente recargar la batería a través de un parche de piel conductor?
Si fueras a tratar ese problema con un tatuaje,
el primer paso sería hacer un tatuaje que condujera la electricidad.
Hemos estado trabajando en un tatuaje de tinta en mi laboratorio.
Y en este momento, podemos aumentar la conductividad de la piel más de 300 veces
con nuestra tinta de tatuaje conductor.
Hay un largo camino por recorrer antes de alcanzar la conductividad
de algo como un alambre de cobre,
Pero estamos progresando y estoy muy entusiasmado con esto
porque creo que podría abrir un nuevo mundo de posibilidades.
para los tatuajes.
Imagino un futuro donde los tatuajes nos permitan...
los cables tatuados y la electrónica tatuable nos permitan
fusionar nuestras tecnologías con nuestros cuerpos
para que se sientan más como extensiones de nosotros mismos,
en lugar de dispositivos externos.
Estos son algunos ejemplos de las nuevas habilidades que podemos obtener
usando la nanotecnología para mejorar nuestros tatuajes,
pero esto realmente es solo el comienzo.
El cielo es el límite de lo que podemos hacer con los tatuajes de alta tecnología.
En el futuro, los tatuajes no solo serán hermosos,
también serán funcionales.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)